centroamérica se une para fortalecerse
ante la tormenta tropical stan en una
gira maratónica del presidente de
honduras juan orlando hernández visitó a
sus homólogos de nicaragua y guatemala
este viernes los presidentes están
sumando sus voces para pedir acceso al
fondo que creó la onu para el cambio
climático y es que vamos a abrir juntos
a perseguir los fondos verdes de manera
que cada una de estas de estos desastres
que son consecuencias de los cambios
climáticos no lo tengamos que estar
afrontando los países con más deudas y
más endeudamiento porque va a llegar un
momento en que no lo vamos a poder
soportar y es que desde el 3 de
noviembre el entonces huracán eta azotó
a centroamérica aunque ya a su nivel
bajo a tormenta tropical y se movió a
eeuu el fenómeno natural dejó más de 200
muertos en la región cerca de 350.000
evacuados y más de 25 millones de
afectados
el salvador respondió con un envío de 30
mil paquetes alimentarios y cerca de 203
cartistas a guatemala y honduras la
unión europea donará 18 millones de
dólares mientras que el banco
centroamericano de integración económica
les transferirá un millón pero ambos
presidentes le pedirán a este banco que
cumpla con el acceso de los fondos
verdes que manejas también le comentaba
al presidente a matthei que ya hablé con
el banco interamericano desarrollo con
su presidente y ayer con el
vicepresidente jaramillo del banco
mundial para que estos multilaterales
que ya tienen manera de es enredar esa
burocracia de los fondos verdes sean
parte de la solución mientras los
centroamericanos buscan salidas para
recuperarse del golpe de eta- nicaragua
y honduras prenden de nuevo sus alarmas
por la tormenta tropical y ota que
llegará a sus costas desde el domingo